at 83 years old chyna's a father of
skiing can still get down the hill and
when called upon by those tasked with
boosting interest in the upcoming
olympic games he's as smooth as skis on
snow water wait i think china will
receive more medals than past years and
will have more champions he says
china is pulling out all the stops to
show the world they're ready to host the
games and safely entertain at 2 000
athletes and the 25 000 support staff
traveling with them the olympic village
will be a tightly controlled bubble with
few opportunities to socialize
automation will play a huge part in that
with meals either lowered from an
overhead grid in the dining hall or
prepared and packaged by robots
olympic gender and sports author helen
jefferson lenski says beijing has
learned from the outbreaks that flared
up at the 2021 games in tokyo on the
other hand it wasn't the total disaster
that a lot of us predicted it would be
and some of that had to do with the
bubbles and some of it had to do with
vaccines and so on
china isn't leaving anything to chance
and its zero covet approach has led to
vast and restrictive measures for
chinese citizens living all over the
country ahead of the games
a third city was put into lockdown this
week impacting nearly 20 million people
a massive effort to disinfect surfaces
and control the virus is underway with
testing sites set up at universities to
complement the country's vaccine booster
program
authorities have also gone to extremes
welding the door shut of a man suspected
of bringing covet into the city of xi'an
and locking employees and customers
inside a shanghai store overnight after
someone was identified as a close
contact with a positive case there is a
global protest
about china even hosting another
olympics it was bad enough in 2008
and their reputation in terms of human
rights violations was very poor then
it's got worse since 2008. but china
doesn't want to talk about any of that
the games are all that matter now
microlight global news toronto